the divisional round begins on saturday
4 35 eastern is the kickoff on
nbc we will be there in santa clara to
see the vikings and the 49ers with an
extended pregame show
and uh with eight teams left four in the
nfc four in the afc that's eight coaches
we're gonna do a four-round draft and
the criteria is this peter king the
playoff head coaches we have the most
confidence in
you will get the first pick if you get
the trivia question correct and i think
that you will the panthers gave matt
rule a seven-year 62 million dollar
contract yesterday
only six players in the nfl have more
than 62 million dollars guaranteed in
their contracts name two of them
russell wilson
and uh
aaron rodgers
[Music]
all right
the others are matt ryan kirk cousins
carson wentz and julio jones you get the
first pick
i'll take andy reed
um i think that the one thing that i
like about andy reid especially when it
comes to
playoff performances and everybody is
gonna ding him for not getting to enough
super bowls for only getting to one the
thing i like about him is with an extra
week he always has a varied
game plan coming up the following week i
think he'll have a lot in his tank for
this first playoff game this weekend
yeah you know i i i got a ton of respect
for him and he's a sentimental favorite
to get a super bowl ring he's been at it
for so long he's been such a great coach
the chiefs are such a fun team they fell
off of people's radar screens this
season and they shouldn't have i think
they're very dangerous heading into the
the division around they're the only
holdover from last year in the round of
eight peter the other seven teams from
last year have all been booted the
chiefs are the only constant and that's
a credit to andy reid what he's been
able to do with his team but you know
there's that the clock management issues
that that that creep up and and and
hopefully he can overcome that hopefully
he can bust through that and he'll have
an opportunity to uh to manage the clock
in a way to get people to say hey you
know what he did pretty well in that one
i'm gonna go with the one guy that uh
well he's not the only one but one guy
who has won a super bowl and who has i
think the best team it's easy to have
confidence in the coach when he's got
the best team and that's john harbaugh
the baltimore ravens they were 14 and
two i love what harbaugh did with the
flexibility adapting the offense to suit
the talents and the skills of his
players specifically lamar jackson and i
i think that that the uh
the scales are tipped a bit in their
favor it's going to take a real upset to
keep them out of the super bowl and
because he's been there because he knows
what it takes because he's weathered a
20-minute blackout in the super bowl
he's ready for anything that may happen
he's been there he's done it and i think
he's ready to do it again
mike with the third pick in the
divisional coach draft
the peter king select
kyle shanahan head coach san francisco
wow i like shanahan at this point i like
shanahan right now and i don't really i
don't think i think there's a chance
that six beats won
but that doesn't that's not a reflection
on the coach it's a reflection
in many ways of the inexperience of so
many players on his team who haven't
played in playoff games before
i trust
that
a more uh you know a greener coach with
a greener team
is going to beat a more grizzled coach
like mike zimmer with a more veteran
team that has played in bigger games
than the san francisco 49ers have and
the reason is
the 49ers this year remind me of the new
york giants of the mid 80s i once asked
bill parcells in their super bowl run
the first time why is the nfce so good
why why every year do they have a
contender for the super bowl if it isn't
chicago or san francisco it's going to
be somebody from the nfc east and he
goes because we're battle tested we play
such a tough schedule and i think the
last like eight weeks of this year
the san francisco 49ers have been in a
bunch of playoff games and have
acquitted themselves well and i like
kyle shanahan's handling of this team
and i think they're going to play very
well this weekend
yeah and i agree with you you've got the
game in new orleans the game in
baltimore that they lost they beat the
saints at the end with that great fourth
and two call from kyle shanahan both
two games against seattle yeah and even
the rams games right the saturday night
game against the rams had a playoff feel
to him for the rams it was a playoff
game because they had to win to stay
alive in their quest to get back to the
postseason so i agree even though only
14 players on the 53-man roster have
playoff experience and obviously
everyone on the vikings do they just
play the playoff game i think those
games the 49ers have played this year
will make a difference and make them
more prepared than they would have been
all right i'm gonna go with pete carroll
he's the other one who has the super
bowl ring i'm a big fan of pelts on the
wall just like bill parcells pete
carroll has done it pete carroll has
russell wilson and i think that
the games that that the seahawks have
won this year so many close games right
pete carroll doesn't freak out in those
moments his team is a reflection of him
and i think that some of these games
they've won they aren't the better team
when they beat the 49ers they weren't
the better team you know when when uh
when they if they can beat the packers
this weekend they may not be the better
team and it's not an easy spot for them
but pete carroll's got the super bowl
win and he's got another one that was
just one bad play call away from
happening so i'll go with pete carroll
you know i'll surprise you right here
mike i'm going to take mike vrabel
and the reason i'm going to take mike
vrable i'll tell you a little story on
saturday night after the game i had just
finished up with with tom brady i was
leaving the patriots locker room
and i ran into mike vrabel and his
family
and mike vrabel when i said to him
i said hey mike
you might have just ended the tom brady
era in new england you might have just
uh
ended the patriots dynasty
and he looked at me and he said
we got to get ready for lamar jackson
forget that other stuff
and and again
the mike rabel
thing is that
he has been there before he's been at
the highest level of football
he has caught a touchdown pass from tom
brady in a championship game you know he
has played under bill belichick for
whatever six years seven years
and to me
i think he has learned this year you got
to make the tough decisions sometimes
you got to yank marcus mariota and mike
you said it earlier might have been a
week or two too late i agree with you
but he did it and they got to a better
spot and right now
the tennessee titans are a good team i
don't think they're going to win in
baltimore but i don't think it's going
to be because the coach
freezes on the sidelines against this
great ravens team
you know it's funny how subjective these
drafts are especially for this kind of
thing with confidence because if you had
given me the first three picks in a row
bang bang bang i would have gone john
harbaugh pete carroll and mike zimmer
and those end up being my three picks
picking second but it's just i mean it's
it's it's eye of the beholder i'll take
mike zimmer and because i've sensed a
change in him not quite to the extreme
of a tom coughlin in 2007 but i think
mike zimmer learned the hard way in 2017
that you can't just rely on what you've
done all year long and just go keep
doing it you have to realize that when
you get to single elimination football
everything you've put on film all year
long and really the year before that
that all has to be studied you have to
scout yourself you have to be thinking
about things you can do what you can
change different curve balls you can
throw that will leave the other team
maybe unprepared for what's to come for
example mike zimmer decided in passing
situations against the saints to take
everson griffin to deal hunter and move
him inside right little things like that
and i got the impression listening to
his press conference after the game on
sunday he's got more stuff too and he
stopped himself from saying i'm gonna
have more stuff for kyle shanahan but i
think zimmer learning from guys like
bill parcells being in big games like
this he was part of super bowl winning
staffs in the past and and you know
he doesn't have many more cracks at this
and he may see that this is his best
chance with an aging defense
and a team that it really doesn't feel
like a young up-and-coming team this is
a team where the window is open and it's
going to close pretty quickly this may
be it and i've got faith that that he's
he's tripped on something he's kind of
in the coaching zone you know how
players get in the zone i feel like he's
in the coaching zone and i got faith
that he's going to come up with
something that's going to at least keep
saturday's game competitive i'm not
going to go crazy and predict the
vikings are going to win it but i think
he's at least going to keep it
competitive
i think what's so interesting about
football as a sport
is that
you know i i walked out of there after
watching that game and i said man the
minnesota defense is voracious they're a
bunch of killers what would have
happened what would have been your
impression coming out of that game
you would have thought that the vikings
defense played well but what would have
happened
if cousins doesn't complete the pass to
adam thielen and then the you know and
then the touchdown passed the jump ball
uh you know to rudolph
you almost you would have been tempted
to say the same old vikings even though
that wouldn't have been right because if
the vikings go down and kick a will
let's field goal they're advancing and
the vikings are not and so so
the quarterback is so ridiculously
important
that's why my next pick and my last pick
is gonna be matt lefleur
you know
i really really like the fact that aaron
rodgers is being semi-dogged
going into his playoff game hey you're
13 and three but hey
aaron rodgers you played better
when they ran mike mccarthy out of town
last year than you did this year when
you go when you went 13-3
so i think matt lafleur has that
advantage to work with this weekend he
knows he has a quarterback who is
playing with another chip on his
shoulder and i think that's just going
to increase
you know the that you know the advantage
that matt lafleur has sunday evening in
green bay
well i guess that leaves billy oh as the
last kid picked in the playground sorry
billy but you know hey you're still
playing right
you're still playing you have a chance
to advance the texans beat the chiefs
during the regular season but uh i mean
i look i i got a lot of respect for bill
o'brien it's just somebody's got to be
number eight it's it's a bunch of great
coaches coaches who are still coaching
for a reason and bill o'brien is good
enough of a coach to go into arrowhead
and win because he did it during the
regular season chiefs are a lot
different now than they were then chiefs
are going to be rested and ready and as
you said peter when andy reid has extra
time he's very dangerous but uh yeah i'm
trying to do i'm trying to throw a
bouquet i feel bad maybe we should have
cut it off at three rounds so somebody
doesn't have to be the last you know
what mike
mike what you can say
is that bill o'brien they they were
these two teams were at full strength
patrick mahomes hadn't been hurt yet he
got hurt the following week
they went in and at times they dominated
you know they they at times manhandle
the kansas city chiefs so hey look the
difference now
is that the steve spagnolo defense has
been absorbed and they're playing it
well and the last six games averaging
giving up 11 points a game kansas city
is really a different team than the last
time
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports